[Music]
getting rekt is quite possibly the worst
thing that can happen to you in a game
of csgo trust me on this one guys
it happens a lot when I play I mean you
guys know how it is right you're holding
Titan ladder room ready to headshot
anyone stupid enough to challenge you
and then Oscar flies down ladder with an
OP and destroys you on the off angle you
thought was perfect
feels bad that's the best thing he's
done all series so an Oscar or all you
want is your 15 minutes of fame and well
this happens I would like to TAS I'm
calling for the score eSports and this
week on best of we're talking about the
best get rekt moments from csgo
now what does it mean to get rekt or to
do the wrecking well it's about hitting
that perfect pixel peak it's about
nailing someone with a dirty jump shot
or getting that double kill collateral
just watch cut off row tations maybe do
it late lurk and actually he's probably
pretty good timing oh wow Nico just
barely misses there's a responsive right
has to do more great custom elu P that's
a big fool oh what a pas an axe that is
beautiful
Pacha [ __ ] the angle isn't necessarily
wide enough for YouTube people to spot
people drop pass and they're gonna set
it up to the beat sake here as well deep
flash going in apex rounds the corner
checks card nobody there it's gonna be
Dupree holding a flat toe he loses the
support from his teammate at door as
well but what is this Dupree you wanna
start to head shots he's still playing
peek-a-boo back here the last man alive
Kenny s not going to be able to
accomplish much as Dupree Hey ends it in
style three head shots in the pistol
what is he waiting for the rotation to
all this time I don't think Forrest saw
his opponents through the flames there
as can often happen coming in Flores
that's disgusting by for the same time
and he's got a kid that is grotesque
that's the best thing is that all series
so far and Oscar might be going one step
better drops down the pop dog groom to
take down Edwards what a shortbread
perfectly that Edward was very good I
have found for just kind of like the
appropriation someone start Guinea for
come on that's enough Seymour be single
be faster than for you Maya
oh my lord here could be huge I mean
they're completely unaware this video a
peon who's covered walls above it he's
gonna make it a lot of noise those fall
into the West we still snort what about
that blue engine the dog kill comes out
as once absolutely insane left for a
hatchet right now what player left on
the side of SK it is only coldzera left
this is absolutely mental he has the
reach a potential the kit is there say
slips out and shuts it down with a sexy
headshot to figure out what's going on
Paulin has an unbelievably deep mind for
this kind of game and he's made his way
up highway if he can just block off all
of whites that might be at only 10
seconds well he must guess the comfort
of headshots in fallen takes in town
again
to point out next place so incredibly
wall right now keep turning
chalks goes all the way back with a
single flash to try and get him inside
of banana but as I mentioned for players
there through your heart ask what jumped
in five red snapback low HP a drink and
the flash pushes the back suddenly
they've got ground to walk towards a
fountain area JDM likewise that's good
is an OPA don't be when you're on your
own you don't have rush if he commits
that but he is not
[Music]
not even maniac knows what to say there
are you kidding me
the only way that he actually makes it
work is a two-for-one and Kenny's just
like yeah whatever you know guys
sometimes get rekt plays go the other
way too you're sneaking up behind
someone ready to knife him in the back
and he turns around and kindly removes
your head from your body when our
Schneider he's right up behind them he
spotted up both of the players doesn't
even need to find one max it's the
things
Magisto punishes Billy doesn't show
about how that one comes around but hey
it happens how embarrassing
oh you want to move my man nope oh
[Music]
goodness he's gonna spit her out that
summer Oh quickly and take him down and
uh yeah I don't think England's winning
this round that he want quick swamp to
the usb to make sure no one else is
getting closer as he has to go for the
reload cold all pushing up tonight cold
deny that cruelty I don't even mind that
he goes down on that because a knife
might have been bigger problems it's
down to this 2 V 3 in both yet to commit
and the timing
it was a given Oh
kid this is gonna be very difficult he
doesn't have like any time to work with
the bump fence could take five seconds
alone he's gonna go for it behind the
fountain Karen's gonna charge him down
is it miss quite a few pistol shots
Kenny yes he wanna kill the round to
show up with this entry power that we
have yet to see holes bad move Humvee
has a perfect opportunity to kill Oscar
but Oscar outright denies it
make sure all would be a big fight of
toxicant I'm this properly and he does
oh he's not able to get the kill go
haters do that even the basic sound
working out Taz is you gonna go for the
night standing on top of the terrace
playing let's do it I did go for it as
just jump on him once
no no separates the CTS back reality
wraps all the way around that the next
great response considering yet no
information no read I'm where he was
nervous - laughs unbelievable
cool aren't you believe the world's top
player just business a massive shot
snacks gets the kill seizes on the
flight from this beat bomb site so cold
even he's at least hidden for now but if
he comes through this murder hole that
cold has no chance at surviving this
battle he's not even appearing it's
gonna be a
three I'm not quite sure I mean babies
thinking it's the back it's gonna be an
auto kill but finally guys we make it to
my personal favorite part of the video
you know getting rekt isn't just
confined to the virtual world sometimes
you can get rekt IRL - thank you for
asking me first of all I would like to
congratulate you and afford the enemy
team faze clan they were really hard it
was a good feeling for us and I would
like to tell you I would like to thank
all of the people who supported with us
it was very wonderful well the stage is
set here Robin you know the two teams
have worked up a bit of spice and they
in the step of both teams there James
and down looking fired up for this one
come on Chad don't be like that you
[ __ ] mark come on
Oh Michio he cheated it was not a fair
game and you know it hey have you seen
what you've done to me in the last two
weeks look act like a [ __ ] you get
treated like one that's what I'm gonna
say whoa
Chad what are you gonna take what are
you say to this look bad it's the cashes
we won the cricket cricket nobody
understands Ricky you got to know what a
crumpet is to understand Ricky I know
you and your cronies over there have
been working on your strategies every
single night you know what I brought
with me an official letter from Kovac
ray and Esther so you guys look nice and
fresh today
clothes are obviously very well ironed
you're looking stunning okay thank you
very much Jason and I see you found that
shirt I brought when I was to get rid of
you so that's Hannah and Momo to get
this one I think if I continue to throw
enough [ __ ] against the wall with my
predictions eventually one will stick
and it feels like this mousesports one
is gonna be he's gonna throw for the
Navi members against the wall well guys
that's all we got for you on best of
this week now look if your favorite get
rekt clip wasn't in this compilation
there's probably a good reason for that
but I know that's not gonna stop you
from flaming us in the comments anyway
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button